[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from Jeff in Florida I
got a new job recently and I have a boss
from hell I'm pretty sure I'm going to
get fired soon the problem is I enjoy
the work and I get paid well I tried
looking for other jobs similar to this
but there is none in my area I feel like
I'm walking on eggshells at work like I
know it's a matter of time before I get
fired I paused baby step two to start
saving in case I get fired I now have
$2,200 saved up I figure we can live on
one income if we sell our cars and take
our kid out of daycare should I start
one looking for a new job to downgrade
everything except child care to prepare
for the worst case scenario if I
downgrade and get a job I'll have that
extra income to pay off debt which is a
substantial amount so yeah it should be
looking for a job right away uh and
taking maybe one or two extra jobs while
looking if you really feel like the shoe
is about to drop and you can get fired
at any moment you just want to be
stacking cash which means making some
extra cash right now if it were this bad
the way you're describing it um I would
be working extra saving extra pausing
some things sure but let's move quickly
um because you know what the work is I'm
not going to accept the reality just
automatically that I've tried looking
for job similar list but there's none in
my area you were looking for one when
you found that one yeah I just never
want to accept that that's just that's a
bull crap
okay you know there's no houses for rent
in this area of course there's houses
for rent in your area you just don't
like them you know so yeah you need to
look for another position immediately
and I you know I'm going to throw in one
other
thing I I do not I cannot tell this from
this
email
but I I Jeff I want you to ask yourself
are you
whining is your boss really the boss
from Hell or are you the lame employee
from
hell you just got the job you walk in
the
door and they ask you to do some work
and you don't like that are you
whining it might not be true yeah but I
would want to ask myself that question
well you actually make a why is it that
you're so freaking useless that even the
boss from hell is going to fire you
quickly well let me throw another
scenario that could be out there too
this could be a boss who may be not the
boss from hell but got a lot of crap
going on in their own life personal life
maybe they're stressed out of their mind
and this boss isn't talking to you with
the sweetest kindest of demeanors and
voice and maybe he's a little grumpy and
and maybe you're not going to get fired
at all maybe they got some rough stuff
going on in their life and you think
because of the way they're treating you
you're going to get fired yeah like are
you whining that's what I'm asking
that's right but what's the cause of
them thinking that the boss is from hell
maybe they're just having a bad day or a
couple bad days and you're not going
everybody that disagrees with you is not
a
narcissist yeah it's interesting you
know everybody that you don't like the
the way they said something does not is
not a toxic work
environment people telling you to do
your job is not a toxic work environment
that's like you buckle up buttercup you
know so I don't know if that's what's
going on or not yeah cu
sometimes that stuff comes up it doesn't
come up here we don't run into it much
cuz you don't even make it through the
interview process if you're going to be
that wimpy here cuz we get crap done and
we don't pull any punches we just I
could be the boss from hell cuz I like
believe you out of work and stuff cuz
you got to outwork me and I'm 63 years
old and been doing this 40 years so keep
up kiddo you know Buckle in so this is
what we're doing I mean if you're not
going to do that you're not going to
like me yeah I agree yeah you
would
oh I'm Jeff I don't know that that's you
but if you're ever facing this I I'm
increasingly hearing and Ken is too in
the career space that every environment
that is that feels momentarily
unpleasant like I'm going to get a
callous is a toxic work environment yes
and that's just the the wussification of
America that's right you're just being a
wuss you know suck it up and and you
know dig you know get the shovel dig the
hole man yeah I mean if that's really
what's going I don't know if that's
what's going on so Jeff ask yourself are
are you whining are you being a wuss is
it really that bad are you exaggerating
and melodramatic and this I mean you
just took the job how could you mess up
the interview that bad yeah well let me
here's here's another clue in this I
enjoy the work he says and I get paid
well people don't enjoy doing stuff they
suck at so he's either delusional and I
don't think he is or I think this is an
emotional situation he doesn't like the
way he's being talked to and treated and
I get that whether he's whining or not
but the issu is don't think that the
boss is going to fire you just because
they're not talking to you with roses
and you know and and treats and you know
that's the issue people quit too soon in
these days because they want to be
coddled that's what I'm saying you can't
get coddled at the work I'm saying and
and it's not a it's not you know I do
not expect anyone to stay in a
real toxic work environment but asking
someone to work yeah and correcting them
if they don't do the work properly is
not a toxic work environment that's
called training yeah okay I you know I
think back to my favorite coach all time
Benny pulk high school basketball if you
would have watched those practices from
outside the gym doors and just watched
his demeanor you would have thought he
was verbally abusing us he wasn't he was
Co well today's world he was but he was
just coaching us and and I think there's
a difference between verbal abuse
bullying and all the stuff we hear about
and then just good oldfashioned
tough-nosed leadership sometimes it's
not all roses and pom poms well I mean
you know you so Jeff I am not accusing
you of that I am suggesting though that
just reading through the email and the
way this is put together that you know
maybe you need to analyze is how much of
this is
you um if it's not you and it's truly
just a guy that's being a twerp and he's
a jerk and he's yelling and screaming or
something I wouldn't ask you to work
there we don't yell and scream at ramsy
we don't cuss at our team we don't do
that we don't abuse we we're not the
bosses from hell but I have been accused
of being that just CU I told somebody
get up off their butt and get their
stuff done okay and if you don't like
that you don't need to work around here
cuz we get stuff done you know we leave
the cave kill something drag it home
pretty regular and when you kill
something usually there's blood so get
ready you know I mean there's there's
crap going on here all right so this is
what's going on
and so you got to decide if that's you
know that that's a part of the equation
here like I I've been fired from jobs to
and you know one time I got fired is
100% my fault it took me a little while
to realize that when I went broke it was
100% my fault you know who got me broke
the idiot it in my mirror and one of the
best things I did in my life is
discovered that he was the problem
create your free every dooll budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life